[Music]
everything is changing Fallon is taking
over The Tonight Show Seth is taking
over uh late night yes everything is
Shifting is there like a possibility
that you springboard into an actual
show let's do something more a classic
APPA poow I got some APPA pows we don't
call it that but okay um okay it's an
older guy not old like but like
middle-aged and he's never had sex so
he's a virgin that's a 40-Year-Old
Virgin you're pitching The 40-Year-Old
Virgin I'm pitching you the the prequel
to 40-Year-Old Virgin which is the
four-year-old virgin well all
four-year-olds are virgins I mean yeah
so they're
gonna
I I don't know what that gesture means
but I don't want to ask
you I'd do anything to be in a movie
what do you think people Like About You
Hair but in your personality I want my
hair what about like what's funny about
you sometimes my hair gets messed up
okay who else would you like to be a
movie with o Kate Upton can she
act let me think about what we would do
with you okay like this so I
think you would be be uh like a friend
to a funny guy and then they just give
you a lot of like you're the guy
who just takes a lot of and it's
brutal and we and you seem so sweet that
it's funny that they're just there's no
end to the viciousness of what they say
about you and we film it and let America
see when they make fun of my boob Shadow
you have a boob shadow in certain shirts
yeah that would be like the kind of joke
we would do are you writing down tit
shadow that actually is a funny could I
use that on girl can I give that to
Lena yeah I just thought that
you had a lot of ideas like that you
come from improv and you can think of
things that other people haven't done
yeah yeah yeah a man in a plaid shirt is
shooting down my movie pitches yes and
I'm like this will be funny for my talk
show is it funny for your talk
show it'll cut
together
oh